Great Android apps use context to
produce experiences that are useful to
users at the right time and
the right place.
Our watch face can show users
contextually relevent data and
react to it by changing styles and
colors in your design.
The first step in designing
a data integrated watch face
is to define the end result.
What information that's available to
your app do you want your users to know
after they've glanced at your design?
Your watch face might use data other
than time, such as weather, calendar, or
fitness data.
Consider including data creatively.
Avoid simply overlaying a time-based
watch face with extra data.
Rather, think about how the data can
be expressed through the lens of time.
For example, instead of designing
a weather-related watch face as
a clock with indication of the current
temperature in degrees overlayed,
you might design a watch face like this
that describes how the temperature
will change over the course of the day,
rain, then sun.
You could use colors to indicate
the kind of weather there might be.
There are lots of possibilities.
And, remember,
keep in mind glanceability for the user.
They're going to be looking at this
watch face a lot during the day.
Less is really more here.
The simpler your message,
the stronger it will be.